joining us with more on the Supreme
Court decision is Jill Schlesinger CBS
News business analyst Jill good morning
good morning so Christina talked about a
little bit there explain now what
happens to people and their student
loans if they thought they weren't going
to have to pay them yeah this is a
problem because it's been an emotional
roller coaster for these borrowers right
we're talking about millions of people
26 million had applied for forgiveness
and 16 million had already been approved
and now that's kaput so what happens is
October 1st that is the day that we
begin repaying and so as Christina said
the interest clock will start accruing
in September but the first payment is
October 1st the most important thing
that every borrower needs to do is make
sure you're in touch with your service
sir and make sure you understand how
much is owed what is the interest rate
and have you enrolled for an auto debit
because this is the way that you can
ensure you won't miss a payment what if
I can't pay what if obviously my
financial situation has changed for
whatever reason I just can't pay right
now well listen there's a few things to
consider the most important is that
there are a lot of different loan
programs for Federal loans so the loan
that you signed up for maybe three or
four or five years ago it's not for the
life of you or the loan there are ways
to modify it there's actually a loan
simulator at studentaid.gov you can go
in and say well what would a different
loan look like specifically there are
income based loan repayment plans this
is important because if your income has
gone down significantly these are plans
that will lower your monthly payment
stretch out the time that you will repay
those loans those can be really good
options for people whose circumstances
can it get deferred any longer at all or
no well I mean listen you can always get
deferment under certain circumstances
okay but I think for the vast majority
of these people after three years they
knew that they were you know again a
year ago I knew I had to pay back a loan
then 10 months ago I got psyched oh my
God I won't and now you have to repay it
again so it really is more emotional
most of the people that I've been
talking to about this have said we've
been preparing for the worst this
temporary on-ramp President Biden has
been talking about explain that a little
bit more well it's interesting because I
think what the Biden Administration is
trying to do is saying we acknowledge
that this is going to be a hard period
for some people and so for this period
of time where things are restarting if
you were to miss a payment the
administration the Department of
Education will not report that to a
credit agency so it will not hurt your
credit score that's really good but you
know they're also the concerns people
say well I don't want to be in default
they said we're not going to put you in
default we're not going to put your loan
in one of those categories where you
sort of have a blemish on your record I
think this is incredibly important a lot
of people who had student loans were
doing really well during the pandemic
they didn't have to pay these loans they
had stimulus checks they paid down other
debt as inflation started to go up they
accrued other other debt and these are
the people that we're most concerned
about how will they COPE in that all
right Jill Schlessinger thank you so
much sure to know